gentlemen i'm dr carol lee director of
the new experimental cosmology center
what makes you qualified to lead our
project yeah yeah
well i have a phd in physics from
berkeley i worked at ibm's watson
research center as lead of the materials
research group and i raised three little
boys which i understand you've been
acting like
sounds like she can handle it
jess we mount a radio telescope on the
roof so that we could get a good read on
the fluctuations in radiation
excellent we'll pick a small region of
the sky and drill down whoa whoa pump
your brakes we need at least a 45 square
degree sector of the sky in order to
take any meaningful readings that's
ridiculous what we need to do is cut a
single linear section across the horizon
no if we don't focus we won't get any
useful data i suggest 20 arc minutes max
the trick is to pick a good spot you
want a trick go see david copperfield
how about i make you disappear
do i need to separate you or can we try
to put our minds together for the
advancement of science
the
second one i know you're new here ma'am
but this is our process they argue i
swoop in and save the day it may seem
unorthodox to you however
the the second one
george
i was carrying pulsers 75 feet up a wet
metal ladder when there was an
earthquake
so i am hanging on for dear life ooh we
should set up several radio telescopes
on different rooftops in an array
you speak mandarin
sheldon that's way
charlize
what are they saying i don't speak
mandarin just a little french
oh really
um
oh
well does anyone here speak klingon nuke
documents
[Music]
lee
sheldon may i have a moment of your time
of course come in
sit
how can i help you
i feel like my contributions aren't
being taken seriously
oh i'm sorry you feel that way
but i'm listening to everyone's
contributions but you're not taking any
of mine
no
but doctors link letter and sturges seem
happy with the direction we're headed
well
i think it's because you're using your
feminine wiles
and what exactly do you think that means
i'm not sure but you are wearing lip
gloss and seem to have good hygiene and
if you're trying to use them on me it's
not going to work
sheldon
i assure you that i'm just trying to do
what's best for the project excellent
then you'll want to set up several
telescopes in an array
i hear you but
wait that's known klingon do you speak
klingon i looked up that one word i had
a feeling it would come in handy
the next evening i put my plan into
action i was just like captain kirk if
captain kirk had to bum a ride from his
meemaw
all i needed to do was get into dr lee's
office and swap the coordinates nothing
could stop me
well here's to male egos and all the fun
that comes with them
[Music]
well what did you do
eventually i realized i'm an
experimental physicist
i can build anything i want to protect
my work
and thanks to my kids i am very familiar
with the movie home alone
after a lot of apologizing a little
begging and a note from my mother i was
allowed to keep my role on the team
when captain kirk faced the no-win
scenario he didn't have blue and yellow
snot for a week
sounds like the ocean
very relaxing
kind of makes the rest of the kitchen
look trashy
ooh it has a temperature boost sensor
so
[Music]
you